what branch of government would be the
maker of the laws of nature and of
nature's God legislation it was lawmaker
right is a lawmaker right what branch of
government would be supreme judge of the
world what branch of government would be
divine providence and the creator would
be like a founder right like a
constitution maker now it's very
interesting that God appears in these
guises and these images the branches of
government when one of the charges in
the middle of the Declaration of
Independence is that the king who's the
executive branch has interfered with the
legislature and the judges he's
suspended the legislature he has removed
judges he is interfered with the trial
by jury the king is trying to be all
three branches but the person who can be
trusted to be all three branches is
actually named in the document only God
right it's a very plain isn't it and if
you think about it for a minute he might
need an authority like that if he's
declaring a rebellion because of the
source of the law up to that moment had
been the king in Parliament and they're
saying no more so King and Parliament
have not passed a law that says you can
cut off from us whenever you want to if
they had they could have used their
authority but they were saying no so
they needed some higher authority laws
of nature